Foreign
Keep your duty to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. For whoever keeps their duty to
Allahel, he will protect and guide him
to the best of his affairs in this in
his religion and in his worldly life. We
must know
that the favors of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala upon us are abundant beyond
measure. And among his favors is that he
has established his servant upon the
earth and provided them with diverse and
many forms of sustenance through which
their bodies are nourished and their
lives are sustained so that he can do
what is pure and lawful and show
gratitude to Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that we have surely established you on
the earth and we have given you
different ways of making your
livelihood.
But how little or how little are you
grateful?
Every Muslim
should be mindful of this reality to
realize that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has made lawful means of earning an
income as allahel says
that is he subhanahu wa ta'ala who has
made the earth manageable for you to
walk on and so go along and eat from his
provision subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and you will surely be resurrected
before Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala we must
all reflect on this part of the verse
that we will be resurrected before
allahel
we will all return to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala our stay in this life is brief
our time in this dunya is limited
And once it ends, we depart and we stand
before Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
There we will be questioned. We will be
questioned about what we did in this
life. Our actions, our words, our wealth
and our choices that we made. Among
these matters that we would be
questioned about is the money and how we
earned it and how it was spent. The
messenger sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
said that a person's feet will not move
on the day of judgment until he is asked
and questioned about four things from of
from those four things is his wealth
where did he earn it from and how did he
spend it
so be honest with yourself Abdullah be
honest with yourself in this life before
you stand before Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and ensure that your answer is a
righteous
But yet
the sad reality my dear Muslim brothers
is that many of the Muslims today both
young and old they show little concern
for this matter. They are heedless
regarding what is halal and haram when
it comes to earning money and this is a
serious problem that needs to be
addressed. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
decreed and he ordained that the people
should work and seek a lawful means and
allahel says
and go and do your actions for indeed
Allah will see what you do the they say
that this verse includes the actions of
the and the therefore every Muslim Abdah
should ensure that their earn earnings
are halal and engage in honest work
without lying or deception.
Islam, it calls the believer to a life
of honest effort. It calls the believer
to a life of dignity. It calls the
believer to a life that is grounded in
piety, honesty, and gratitude. And so we
must look at the examples that came
before us and the strength and the
honesty of the companions
collects aith in his narrated by
who said that her father Abu Bakr
who had a servant and sometimes this
servant this young man he used to bring
him food. One day Abu Bakr he ate this
food and the young man said to him he
said to him do you know what this food
is or do you know where this food has
come from? Abu Bakr Sadi said what is
it? Where is it come from? The young man
he replied and he said
he said I once practiced soothsaying
magic sorcery
for a man in Jah before he was a Muslim
and he said even though I was not
skilled at it I was not good at it
anyway but I deceived the man. So here
the product is haram number one and
number two there is deception in the
transaction.
He said I deceived him and then he said
I later met that man and he paid me for
the work. He paid me for this magic and
sorcery and he said that is what you
just ate from. Mentioning this to Abu
Bakr Sud. So what was his reaction? What
was the reaction of the best of this
ummah after the prophets and the
messengers?
He put his fingers in his mouth and he
put his fingers down his throat and he
vomited the food that he consumed from
this haram income.
That such
was the closest companion of the
messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He
would not tolerate that anything
unlawful remained in his body out of
fear of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
purity for his provisions.
This is the standard that was set by the
best of this um who understood the
weight of accountability and understood
the weight of standing before Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So we should be
careful about what we earn and what we
consume.
Ensuring that it is pure and lawful.
Ensure that our shops
are not selling alcohol. Ensure
that we are not earning money through
ribba. Ensure
that we are not selling drugs. Ensure
that we are not handling stolen goods.
And the list goes on and on and on. Let
us not fill our stomachs with haram. Let
us not fill our family stomachs with
haram. Do not pursue this temporary
wealth, this temporary life through
haram at the expense of the hereafter.
It is better Abdullah to have little
when it is pure because it comes with
blessings over a fortune that is impure
because that comes with ruin and ruins
everything that is around you. and the
women in the home and the children, the
young ones in the home, they should
understand this that when times are hard
and income is low in the home that they
should be patient as long as the bread
winner is honest and earning it in halal
means. A hadith is reported by
who said a man passed by some of the
companions. He walked by some of the
companions with the messenger
sallallah.aii wasallam there and then
they noticed his strength and his energy
and they said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
if only he used this strength in the
path of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala." The
messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said to them and he taught them. He said
if he went out striving to provide for
his young children then that is in the
path of Allah. And if he went out
striving to provide for his elderly
parents then that is in the path of
Allah. And if he went out striving to
keep himself away from begging and
asking the people then that is in the
path of Allah. And if he went out to
show off and to boast, then that is in
the path of shan. How noble Allah is it
to strive with pure intentions and
lawful means. And how dangerous is the
pursuit of wealth that is tainted with
impurity.
So let us examine our earnings.
how we earn our money, how we earn our
wealth and let us examine our hearts and
see what is pleasing to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Are we teaching the next
generation? Are we teaching our children
and the young ones these rules and these
principles? Do we tell our children
about the dangers of haram money? Are we
instilling this and engraving it into
their minds when they are young that
they have to avoid the haram income? Or
are we suddenly surprised when our young
brothers are out there selling drugs and
stealing? As parents and as elders in
the community, there needs to be an
active effort in showing the youth the
alternatives and the many ways of
earning halal income. We need to be
giving them the knowledge about
different professions and different
skills and different business
opportunities that are available and our
alternative.
Let this be a reminder to myself and my
dear brothers and I asked Allahel to
purify our hearts and our wealth.
>> [clears throat]
>> Alhamdulillah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
that this ayah is a permission from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that when the
salah is complete in the masjid that
Allah allows you to go out into the land
and seek lawful means to go out and to
work and to trade and to fulfill your
worldly needs and seek the bounty of
allahel
and we should always remember
But you feel
that there is no creature on earth
except that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
providing for it. And so we must turn to
Allah for our sustenance have this in
our have this in our our reliance on
allahel
that our sustenance comes from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. They come through
the means of dua and effort and movement
and striving. And Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says
that whoever keeps their duty to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala he makes a way out
for him from any difficulty and he gives
him provisions sustenance from places he
did not expect. This is a reminder that
provisions are in the hands of
Allahawel.
It is not in the hands of the people.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is the one who
opens the doors when all paths seems to
be closed. And it is Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala who enriches the hearts before he
enriches the pockets. So be from those
in this life who earned halal for them
and their families. Be from those who
contributed to society positively. Be
from those who built massagid, who cared
for others, who gave in charity. Be from
those who helped the needy. [snorts] Be
from those who set up beneficial
projects to serve the ummah. And
wherever you put forth, you will see it
reward with Allahel.
A believer should always be full of
effort. Abdullah should always be full
of perseverance regardless of the
challenges that face a Muslim in his
life. A Muslim is someone who is
resilient. A Muslim is someone who is
strong. And so he stands up to these
challenges and he places his reliance on
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And the youth
should know that they have abilities
that can be used for good. They
shouldn't underestimate this and they
shouldn't allow shan to lead them to
what is haram. And yeah Abdullah if you
are involved in haram or you are having
haram income then change your condition
today try and change Abdullah and rely
on Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for help
and rely on Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
for guidance because our time in this dy
is precious
and our time is limited. I ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to purify our wealth
and to purify our hearts.
I ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to rid
us and to rid the youth and to rid this
um of haram and haram incomes.
Allah subhana wa ta'ala ask you to aid
us in worshiping you and being grateful
to you. Ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
give us what is good in this and good in
the and to keep us away from the
hellfire. Ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to aid the needy all across the world. I
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to help
those who are in need from the Muslims
around the world. I ask Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to aid those instin Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to maintain the
peace that they have and to maintain
safety for them. and ask Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to help our brothers in Sudan
and to feed them and to clothe them and
to aid them in their times of need.